bonjour à jour là était qu'est-ce que
vous allez nous apprendre aujourd'hui
élu aujourd'hui on va faire du pâté de
serre au foie gras et en croûte faut
être accompagnée de fumées de vieux ceps
que j'ai déjà goûté avec ce qui est
vraiment bon c'est délicieux et puis
vous n'allez pas me dire quand même que
vous allez mettre des coquilles saint
jacques dussault mon jeu pato quoi dans
un pâté de tête parce que je vous
croirais pas non là on va faire une
carbure de choix de poisson en croûte ou
si un couteau si c'est ça c'est ça fait
drôle mais c'est délicieux alors pour
nous tromper vous avez mélanger tous les
ingrédients ce qui fait qu'on ne sait
plus qui va dans quoi alors vous allez
tous nous les énumérer et puis c'est
vrai il fera le tri entre il rappelait
alors on commence par la droite et on y
va
voilà alors il nous faut du porto il
nous faut de madère et nos fautes de
l'armagnac il nous faut deux magnifiques
7 comme l'avait été cueillir dans votre
forêt des landes édition jamal et son
beau il nous faut de l'échalote une
faute de l'oignon d'essai pour lundi il
nous faut du céleri nous faut des
carottes des oeufs et une forme
magnifique faudra on peut faire mais
quand il est moins beau du navet de
l'oignon nouveau des champignons de
paris du thème des haricots verts bien
entendu des coquilles saint jacques du
saumon de la lotte et du jambon et me
voilà et maintenant on va faire
attention quoi pour la terrine de cerf
et quoi pour la garbure deux poissons
alors on commence par la terrine de cerf
et qu'est ce qu'on va et viens on va
faire revenir de l'échalote
mais déjà le font très bien mon âge
aurait dit fond d'huile
oui qu'est ce que vous allez faire et
bien maintenant je vais faire le fut
mais de simples on va commencer le fumé
de moi lançait alors qu'est ce que vous
mettez alors mon brouillon proviande
trois viandes c'est à dire que vous avez
mis là les légumes que l'on met dans
tous les poteaux fut
ni qu'elle vit en moi alors j'ai mis du
veau élue boeuf live et yahoo
les duos or voilà un peu de charme
désuet oui mais où
alors là je vais mettre du bouillant oui
voilà et je vais mettre du porto est là
il faudrait à peu près m la même
quantité de bouillon et de porto c'est
bon alors vous pouvez les lire au fil
très longue
oui et on va y mélanger voilà très bien
et je vais m'y mettre mais simple dedans
oui voilà très bien merci
quel que c'est qu'elle que sais je
pouvais pas sur un faux pas des masses
et la sphère l'oeil à peu près pour la
nôtre cuillère et on va se faire ça va
se faire tout seul il faut que ça puisse
tout doux sont raccourcis faisant
longtemps oui hélas pendant ce temps et
bien vous verrez parlent et je crois
qu'il va falloir s'occuper du volet on
va faire des lardons comme on dit de
jambon alors je vais couper en tranches
de jambon il faut kotobi coupe bien
entendu
voilà voilà en faire des lardons
merci micheline c'est bien vous les
couper en petits dés mali des 13 bon
jambon de pays bas de chez vous de gens
m'ont gasco et qu'est ce que vous allez
faire avec des bus envers l'autre dans
la poêle avec son gîte la note qui sont
dorées juste derrière toi comme il faut
voilà les anglais ne rôdeur et tout ça
c'est du gendarme allemand oui j'ai une
fille très vite et est aujourd'hui a
ajouté je vous rajoute g7 alors je
voulais pas là et quand même la i télé
fait avec de l'échalote la madone
tablant sur brawn et non parce que ça
qui ferait autrement se limiter à autre
chose et vous indiquer la salade aussi
et pour faire un papier ce très bien bon
moment je connais ça le tfc très
parisien vous savez un centre agace que
vous allez vivre et de l'ail et du
persil est bel et bien mais avec le
jambon et l'échalote vous allez voir ça
va aller c'est un papier qu'on fait est
bon c'est pas une omelette aux cèpes pas
semblé enfin oui alors si les points
reconnaît où il vient remonter la haye
ah oui parce que des gens morceau va
seul un petit peu mais le foire soyez
généreux mesdames si vous avez mis une
botte de pain c'est peut-être que vous
avez un long ballon de m janvier ce sera
chaud et puis c'est tout à peine à peine
à peine voilà dans les feuillets de
soissons est un peu partout
bonnart qu'on ne sente pas ou blanc soit
près d'un type qui sont présents et puis
après ça est-ce qu'il faudra encore
faire préparer à terry on va préparer la
terrine on va mettre notre pâte
feuilletée dans la terrine de foie gras
maïté qu'est-ce qu'on en fait bientôt
mais pas tout de suite pas tout de suite
bien qu'est-ce qu'on fait avant eh bien
on va faire notre terry de maintenant je
vais à huile et bien oui nous l'aurait
peut-être d'ouvrir à c'est à cause d'
appâter crier grâce et déjà même faire
voir cette actualité c'est une faute
mais on n'a pas fait à l'antenne parce
qu'on l'avait déjà fait dans une autre
émission wissant pas recommencer
toujours la même je refais les
d'ailleurs elle est meilleure quand on
l'a fait la veille bien cela posé il
faut qu'elle soit posée la pâte
feuilletée surtout faire attention quand
même échoué en profiter le rémois real
avant ce dont je vais m'en de l'armagnac
dans mes soeurs un peu d'art magna dont
l'offre a brûlé c'est quand même une
petite giclée
gicler au piano c'est maïté très bien
droit à leur part fait je vais remuer
votre refus mais là il va bien il est
joli
il veut réduire encore un peu non non et
les voleurs très joli la peau est alors
avec ça et je vais mettre un peu le
simple de leur amitié
oui quels sont vos - sa mort après laon
peu partout dans les cours comme
instruction de fly et oui et c'est là
qu'intervient le foie ah voilà
et comme ce choix est plutôt joli et
plutôt gros je vois déjà ce qu'on va en
faire et on va l'escalot paix et ça va
être des petits d'escalopes style
humanité c'est à dire assez charmant il
faut pas te rendre un hommage comme il
faut ce qu'il faut c'est à dire que le
jour on a décidé de faire de la bonne
cuisine il faut ce qu'il faut
les autres jours on peut les voir les
boîtes de petits pois au déni ou lien la
voie le jour il faut que ce soit bon
faut que ce soit bon alors on va le
pousser un petit peu non comme ça pour
que ce soit bien clair la voilà la y en
a partout
on va remettre notre couche de sel voilà
vous savez on est vous que ça se soit
mauvais ça paraît difficile vilaine ça
peut pas être mauvais c il faut tout ça
y est saviez bien calculer bien sûr et
maintenant qu'est ce que vous allez
faire mettre au four doit on va faire un
chapeau à se mettre à couvert qui sera
fermée chapeau alors là avec le jaune
d'oeuf
je vais passer tout le bord oui c'est
une jaune d'oeuf attendit vrai pro vie
toujours vous l'avez mélanger avec la
voile avec et le dos avec de l'eau parce
que sans fin il serait trop payés là je
vais chercher l'autre renverse le
couvercle autrement dit un autre
rectangle de rapidité que je pose le
plus simplement du monde
oui on tapote un petit peu le bord pas
trop précaire l'amader
rifle c'était bien moi j'ai dû coller et
après on coupe on n'a pas trop un nom
comme ça on suit d'abord oui non voilà
on a bien chauffer le four en lamy au
maximum il ne faut pas trop pas trop et
pas trop bien c'est choquant mais à ce
jour été non voilà voilà bien fermé
c'est bien alors maintenant je veux pas
des journées à nouveau oui avec mon geof
dessus pour le rendre parfait pour faire
joli pour le rendre oui pour que la
phase finale de la c1 brian atwood
je vais décider non c'est pas difficile
là on va lui faire des petits dessins
avec le dos du couteau très léger vous
pas fabre et oui là mais ça l'aide à moi
ne va pas monter à fait pour faire mieux
a éclaté a éclaté lorsque le feuilleton
des grès j'ai en fait j'ai fait pas du
trou voilà et puis y'a plus qu'à mettre
au four et laissez cuire
combien de temps vous croyez à peu près
dix minutes un quart d'heure dix minutes
un quart d'heure la présence quand votre
pouvoir faire la garbure de presse y te
ment mais rien de plus facile
vous allez voir là j'ai fait revenir
tous des petits légumes que vous avez
eue nous verrez c'est à dire on avait
du poireau des cas mode us et les couper
en jeu viennent très très très faim des
haricots verts et des navets outils
coupé très fin et maintenant et
maintenant je mêle à l'autre voilà le
cellulaire quoi le poids face à la juve
à poivre
oh pardon arrêter notre pêche après je
prendre son bain oui les tranches de
saumon fournaise qu'après film et ont
appelé tous les we jeu mais la police
est allée bien q vous avez vu julien
revenus les faire revenir saler et
poivrer bien entendu les coquilles saint
jacques les voilà tous les trains les
coquilles saint jacques
que là encore il s'agit d'une soupe
individuelle mais une soupe quel repas
du soir complet était bonne alors là
c'est pareil j'avais laisse aller et les
poivrer et b ça y est alors qu'est-ce
que vous ajoutez depuis quand ya pas de
soupe là attendez je vais rajouter un
peu de fumée
je vais retourner voilà c'est très vite
fuyait les coquilles saint-jacques
pareil alors qu'ils coûtent chaque côté
xavier jamais vu ça y est voilà je vais
mettre un peu de bouillon et bien du
fudec passion du vin vient du tunnel on
avait préparé les parures des légumes à
12,6 au soin de l'oignon découvir ans
tout ce qui donne bon les voilà un petit
peu de nouvelles
c'est pas de l'armagnac aujourd'hui
remords c'est du mardi après parce que
selah sue voilà un peu de manière à
lévis et puis ça y est un petit peu et
ça y est voilà voilà on laisse bouillir
la ligue et petit instant et on va le
mettre maintenant je vais sortir mes
poissons
oui je vous tiens le fabuleux voilà la
fourchette y a pas besoin de recours
demandant alors les coquilles les
coquilles un petit peu de l'autre
oui et le reste ça va aller avec d'assez
bon voilà c'est bon vous mais cette côte
et voilà à mettre ça de côté
oui alors maintenant ici deux hommes
dans une petite soupe hier individuel je
vais mettre les légumes les légumes
je vais penser qu'il est poussé on va
tout mettre tout le reste puisqu'il
reste de leur diffusion d'un monde
qu'ils font là sybase rapide et ben
voilà on va mettre un petit peu non je
vais forcer le jure a déclaré le point
sur vous le mettez dessus la wii mais je
vais mettre à faire au mieux pour
remettre tout de suite sous les pinceaux
de poser délicatement la lente
les coquilles télé free coquilles
saint-jacques lisser vos récents c'est
pas beau tout ça c'est beau c'est bon on
en mangerait là c'est pas beau ça
et à voir lire après le jure avec ce jus
quand je vais m attention vigilante à ce
niveau voilà à vos marche bon poids
bonne mesure
ces prêts à tout à fait là maintenant on
va y mettre un peu cool j ai souvent dit
oui au tour donc et on va voir tout il y
aura quoi rire pour coller même
opération que la précédente
voilà et vous vous attrapez votre petit
couvercle de patte verte et le voilà on
appose on la colle
et on fourre tout simplement exactement
et les 2 7 6 10 8
[Musique]
le pâté de cèpes au foie gras en croûte
accompagné d'un fumée deux vieux c'est
oui
j'ouvre louvre allez courage et bisous
apporter un peu de ce fumet vous parler
maintenant à la regarder comme là c'est
bien vous savez c'est bien on pourrait
le sortir
voilà en fait on pourrait sortir une
tranchée la compagnie de la source ne
serait pas plus mal
mais il faudrait noter l'autre avant que
ce soit c'est bien d'autres voilà allez
vous creusez un petit chapeau et ont
enlevé un morceau qu'on voit vraiment ce
cas de dollars surtout cela on ouvre la
croûte et bien vous d'essayer au revoir
et à bientôt
à bientôt mois
[Musique]